in this video you're going to learn how
to graph logarithmic functions and we're
going to go through six different
examples I'm going to show you two
different methods so you can pick the
method that works best for you or
corresponds to what you're learning in
your class or what your teacher's
showing you so let's dive in and I'll
show you how this works
so the first thing I want to talk about
is when we graph a logarithmic function
we want to understand that logs and
exponential functions they're inverses
of each other and you previously learned
how to graph exponential functions
and when you find the inverse is what
you do graphically is you reflect it
over this line Y equals X so when you
reflect it you're going to get a graph
that looks something like this this is a
logarithmic graph so what you can do is
you can rewrite the log into exponential
form and I'll show you how to do that in
some of these problems so let's talk
about uh example number one here where
we have y equals log base 3 of X so how
do we graph that well remember how we
said that logs and exponential functions
are inverses so what you can do is you
can exponentiate or raise both sides
using this base three so if these bases
match the exponential function and the
logarithmic functions they undo each
other so you now what we have is we have
this equation x equals 3 to the Y power
so we'll make a table and we'll plug in
some values for y not X but y so
negative 1 0 and 1. so 3 to the negative
1 when you have a negative exponent you
take the reciprocal so 3 to the negative
1 is going to be 1 3
to the 0 anything to the 0 power is one
and then three to the first is three so
now if we plot these points let's see
we've got right one-third down one
uh one zero so that's right one up zero
and then right three up one
and here's your
logarithmic graph right there now when
you want to find the domain what you
want to remember is that you can't take
the log
of 0 or a negative number so whatever is
here you can you can basically say x
equals zero and that'll give you this
vertical line which is right here on the
y-axis okay and if you want to find the
domain this quantity here has to be
greater than zero because it can't be
zero can't be negative so that'll be
your domain everything greater than zero
or if in your if you're in precalculus
you could write this as 0 to Infinity as
your domain okay and then notice that
this graph goes down and gradually up up
so the range is going to be all real
numbers or if you're in precalculus and
you're learning the interval notation
you could say negative Infinity to
positive Infinity
so that's the basic idea is basically
rewriting this into the exponential form
and then you can make a table and graph
let's look at a little bit more
complicated uh problem now where there's
some Transformations involved so if we
go over here to example number two I
mentioned there's a couple different
methods to use here
the first method we're going to talk
about is using the transformation so you
could say well this plus 2 what does
that do to the graph this minus one what
does it do to the graph well the plus 2
when it's grouped with the X like this
it has the opposite effect it's actually
going to shift the graph left two and
this minus one this affects the vertical
Direction up and down it's going to
shift the graph down one so you could
think of this point right here as like
your new starting point okay or like
your new origin then you can focus in on
this parent function this basic function
y equals log base 4 of X graph that but
from the shifted origin so that's one
way to do it so let's let's talk about
that so if we exponentiate both sides
using this base 4 these are inverses of
one another 4 to the Y power is equal to
X that's just Rewritten in exponential
form
plug in some easy numbers I usually plug
in negative 1 0 and 1 just some small
numbers 4 to the first is 4 but a
negative you take the reciprocal so this
is one-fourth four to the 0 is 1 because
anything to the 0 power is one and then
four to the first is four I'm going to
plot these points from here so what I
can do is I can go I'll write 1 4 down
one right one up zero right four one two
three four up one and you can see this
graph is going to look something like
this now
the domain remember how we said if you
set the SQL to zero you can find your
domain whatever is grouped with the X
here so X plus 2 equals zero subtract
two x equals negative two
gives you your vertical asymptote
but if you want to find the domain you'd
make this a an inequality X plus 2 is
greater than zero X has to be greater
than negative two or if you're in uh
precalculus and you're learning the
interval notation you can say from
negative 2 to infinity and then the
range is all real numbers okay it goes
down and up forever and ever or you can
say negative Infinity to positive
Infinity so that's one option another
option okay is you could set up your
table okay just with y equals log base 4
of X and then apply the transformations
to the table so you could say hmm plus 2
that's going to shift the graph left to
I can subtract 2 from all these y values
so this would be two this would be
negative one this would be negative one
and three-fourths cross off the old X
values the minus one shifts it down one
that means they're subtracting one from
all of the Y values cross out the old
ones now you can just plot these points
from the original origin okay so that's
another way to do it using the table or
you can use a shifted origin another
option for you those ones kind of go
together the other option for you is
just to rewrite this
in exponential form so what we're going
to do is
we're going to try to get this x by
itself here so what we're going to do is
we're going to add 1 to both sides so
that's going to be y Plus 1. equals log
base 4 of X Plus 2.
then we're going to exponentiate both
sides using Base Four
so those are inverses then do each other
kind of like adding and subtracting or
multiplying and dividing or squaring and
square rooting and then we can subtract
2 from both sides
and now what do we have we have 4 to the
Y plus 1 power minus 2 equals x now this
equation we can make a table
and pick some values for y so you might
want to pick like let's just say
negative 2 negative 1 and 0. plug that
in get your X values and you can graph
it like that so all we did was we got
rid of the log okay by exponentiating
but we're trying to get this x by itself
here so we're just trying to solve for x
by working from the outside in and now
you're familiar with the exponential
notation we can just plug in for y and
solve for x so a couple different
options let's look at a few more
examples
okay let's take a look at example number
three now we have y equals log base one
third of x minus three plus two so let's
look at a couple different options here
so this one we wanted to graph we could
think of Shifting this graph right three
and up two so you write three up two you
can think of this as your new origin you
could draw your vertical asymptote right
through here that's the line x equals
three and then you can focus in on the
parent function which is y equals log
base one third of X now what I like to
do is I like to exponentiate or raise
both sides using the same base one-third
and what that does that writes this in
exponential form so what I'll do is I'll
plot some values for y negative 1 0 and
1 1 3 to the negative 1 is 3 because the
negative you take the reciprocal
one-third to the zero is one anything to
the zero power is always one and then
one-third to the first is itself
one-third what we're going to do is
we're going to plot these points from
this new origin so we're going to go
right three
down one
right one up zero
and then write a one-third up one
and so your graph looks something like
this
okay and you might be saying well Mario
I thought the log graphs look like this
right well if you think about graphing y
equals one-third to the X see this is an
exponential decay function when that
base is between 0 and 1 it's going to go
down to the right and then if you
reflect it over the line Y equals X
you're going to grab get a graph that
looks something like this
okay and so that's why that graph looks
like that now another way to do this
problem is
you can take your parent function like
we just did right here and then once you
have your table you could add 3 to all
the x coordinates so that'd be like 6 4
and 3 and 1 3. and then the plus 2
shifts everything up to so if you add 2
to all of the Y coordinates you could
plot these points but you'd plot them
from the original origin zero zero and
then the other option is what you can do
is you can solve for x so what I would
do is I would subtract 2 from both sides
of this equation so it'd be y minus 2
equals log base 1 3
of x minus 3 and then I would
exponentiate both sides
okay that way these are inverses they
undo one another and then I'm going to
add 3 to both sides of this equation so
you're going to get 1 3 y to the Y minus
2 power plus 3 more equals X and then
what you can do is make a table just
plug in some values for y get your x
coordinates and then plot from the
original origin so you have a few
different options with these problems
whichever way you like to approach it
now as far as the domain see whatever is
it in the parentheses here a group of
the X this has to be greater than zero
so if I solve that inequality add 3 to
both sides X has to be greater than 3 or
you could say an interval notation from
3 to infinity and then the range for
these law graphs is always going to be
all real numbers
okay let's take a look at example number
four now this one is a little bit more
challenging just in the sense of the way
that it's written so you see this 4
right here watch carefully what I'm
going to do is since this is a positive
4 I'm going to put the 4 over here and
I'm just going to subtract the 4 there
so I'm not really doing anything to both
sides of the equation I'm just putting
the 4 over here instead of in front
just to kind of rewrite it a little bit
now this one we have a negative in front
of the log and what do you think that
negative does to the graph well it's
going to reflect it over the x-axis it's
going to make all the Y values the
opposite sign
so what you can do you can still do like
we were doing before you can say this is
going to shift right one up four
you can think of that as like your new
origin here's your vertical asymptote
this is the line x equals one remember
vertical lines are x equals lines
and then what we'll do is we'll focus on
this parent function here y equals
negative log base 2 of X now you might
want to multiply both sides by negative
one
and then when you exponentiate both
sides you can see this is 2 to the
negative y power equals x so we'll go
ahead and plot some values for y like
negative 1 0 1 a negative times a
negative is U positive 1 2 to the first
is 2. 2 to the 0 power is 1 and 2 to the
negative 1 is going to give you one-half
plotting from here now right to
down one would be right about here
right one zero would be right about here
write a half up one would be right about
here and you can see your graph
is looking something like that domain
would be X is greater than one
or you can say from one do Infinity if
you're using the interval notation range
is all real numbers the other option you
could do is you could think about the
Transformations you could say starting
from the inside working your way out you
could say minus one that's going to
shift the graph right one which is going
to add 1 to our X values so 3 2 1 and a
half
and then this negative is going to make
all the Y values the opposite so this
would become a positive one zero
negative 1 and then the plus 4 shifts
everything up four so adding 4 to the
Y's is going to be 5 4 and 3 and then
you can plot these points from the
original origin
and the other option is you could try to
solve for x so what you could do is you
could subtract 4 from both sides so y
minus 4 equals negative log base 2 of x
minus 1 multiply both sides by negative
one so that would give you negative y
plus four
equals log base 2 of x minus 1
exponentiate both sides using base two
these are inverses and then add 1 to
both sides so you'd have 2 to the
negative y plus four plus one equals X
and then now you can just use this
entire equation plotting from the
original origin
pick some values for y get your x
coordinates and and plot so whichever
method you like the best you know go
with that method let's look at two more
examples see if you can do these on your
own okay pause the video see what you
can do for number five and number six
now for number five if I was going to
approach this problem again remember
there's different ways to do it but what
I would probably do on this one is
look at the Transformations so I would
start with the parent function which is
y equals log base 5 of X and then I
would exponentiate both sides using base
five
and so this is our basic function 5 to
the Y equals X so if I plug in some
small numbers here 5 to the negative one
is one-fifth five to the 0 is 1 and 5 to
the first is five
but then working from the inside out the
plus 3 is going to shift the graph left
three so if I subtract 3 from all these
x coordinates that's going to give us 2
that's going to give us negative 1 and
that's going to give us a negative 2 and
4 5.
then this 2 here is going to be a
vertical stretch by a factor of 2 which
is going to multiply all the Y values by
2. and then this minus 1 is going to
shift the graph down one which is going
to subtract 1 from each of these
y values
so now you can see here's some points
we've got negative two and four-fifths
negative three which is right about here
negative 1 negative one is right about
here and 2 1 is right about here
okay so now we can see that our vertical
asymptote if we set this equal to zero X
plus three equals zero x equals negative
three
is our vertical asymptote and our graph
this is just a rough sketch but our
graph is going to look something like
like this okay now you can be a little
bit more precise about finding where it
crosses the y-axis and the x-axis by
setting the opposite variable equal to
zero but for now this is just a sketch
now the other option is what is to think
about
um
solving for x so we could say let's add
one to both sides so that's going to
give us y plus 1 equals 2 log base 5 of
X plus three
divide both sides by two
and then exponentiate both sides using
base five so that's going to give us
five to the Y plus 1 over 2 power equals
X plus three then subtract 3 from both
sides
equals X and now you can see
we can use this equation just plug some
values in for y and solve for x and you
can plot your points like that so A
couple different options Transformations
or rewriting solving for x let's jump to
the last example number six here how
would you graph this one
well
I'll start off by doing the
Transformations again I'd start with the
basic parent function which is y equals
a log base one half of X let's
exponentiate both sides by raising both
sides using base one half this is our
basic function if we plug in some values
for y
we get 2 2 1 half to the zero is one and
one half to the first is one-half but
then talking about our Transformations
working from the inside out the minus 2
is going to shift the graph right to
which is like adding 2 to our x
coordinate so that would be 4 3
2 and 1 half
the negative 3 is going to multiply all
the Y values by negative three so this
is three zero negative three
and then the plus two shifts the graph
up two that's going to give us 5 2 and
negative 1. so now we can plot these
points right four up five
which is right about here
3 2 which is right about here and two
and a half
negative 1 which is right about here as
far as the vertical asymptote goes you
can set what's inside the parentheses
here equal to zero and that's going to
give you x equals two
that's our vertical asymptote and you
can make an inequality and make this has
to be greater than zero so X has to be
greater than two that's our domain or we
could say from 2 to Infinity
and so you can see this graph is going
to look something like
this what happened was you can see that
the one-half originally the graph would
look like this right
then we shifted it right to we reflected
it over the x-axis and stretched it by
three and then we shifted it up two so
that's the graph there so and then this
one here I think we talked about let's
see the domain would be from negative 3
to infinity and the range is all real
numbers so great job if you're able to
follow these examples if you want more
practice or you'd like to see more
explanation follow me to the other video
I did previously talking about how to
graph logarithms right here and I'll see
over in that video